there's a whole lore about dreaming in
fact Sigmund Freud wrote a book called
the interpretation of dreams which many
people think is the the foundation of
psychoanalysis well scientists now have
looked at 40 in psychology and the brain
using all these modern techniques and
first of all we realize that perhaps
Sigmund Freud wasn't totally wrong
there are many text books which simply
dismiss Freudian psychology calling it
nuts that is nothing but the sexual
fantasies of a repressed uh Venetian
scientists of the last century but now
we realize there's more to it first of
all the unconscious mind we can actually
see the brain in motion and we realize
that much of the activity is totally
unconscious just like what Freud
predicted and Freud also said there is
the ego the it'd and the super-ego that
we are in a constant battle with our
desires and our conscious and we see
that now with brain scans the ego is
basically your prefrontal cortex that is
who you are when you wonder where am i
anyway well you're right there you are
sitting right behind your forehead and
then your desires we see the pleasure
center right there the center of the
brain that is the libido we see where
the pleasure center is located and then
your conscience is right behind your
eyes the orbital frontal cortex right
behind your eyes is where your conscious
is and so we actually see that in motion
if you were to see a chocolate cake you
would see these three parts of the brain
going Zippity back and forth like a
ping-pong ball because you're constantly
debating the pleasure of eating a
chocolate cake versus how fat you're
going to become and all the sugar and
the calories that you don't really need
so we see the beginnings of Freudian
psychology coming out of of brain scans
and now dreams Freud had a whole
collection of interpretation of dreams
scientists have looked at and said
nonsense now we understand the
physiology of the
process and we realized that it comes at
the back of the brain a very primitive
part of the brain and that certain parts
of the brain are shut off when you dream
first of all your prefrontal cortex is
basically shut off it's quiet your
orbital frontal cortex that is your
conscience is also shut off but that
part of the brain is your fact-checker
the part of the brain that says hmm
that's not right something's wrong is
right behind your eyes that's shut off
what is active when you dream is your
amygdala and what does your amygdala
govern fear and emotions and so right
then you know that when you dream the
active part of the brain is not the fact
checker not the rational brain it's the
emotional brain the fearful brain that
is active when you dream and then
there's some superstition called lucid
dreaming where you can actually control
the direction of the dream
well that superstition last year became
science fact at the Max Planck Institute
in Germany they were able to show once
and for all that lucid dreaming is
testable reproducible it is real and
here's how they did it they took a
person who was about to go to sleep and
told them that when you dream clench
your right fist and then clench your
left fist now when you dream you are
paralyzed you cannot move when you dream
otherwise we be able to carry out all
sorts of horrible things and destroy
ourselves so we are paralyzed when we
dream but when this person went into a
dream state you can clearly see that the
brain initiated orders to clench your
right fist and your left fist in other
words he was conscious while he was
dreaming there are many Buddhist texts
many tax hundreds of years old that give
you the outlines of how to control
dreams lucid dreaming we now know that
it's not hogwash that you can actually
do this you can actually direct the
course of your dream and then one day we
may be able to brain scan the brain as
you dream and put it on a screen in
which case somebody will be able to see
you dream and know the direction of the
dream and you are conscious of the
process in other words the movie
Inception is not totally hogwash